it's right off the bat
get rid of that crap uh that i don't i'm
not going to the movie theater to eat
vegetables okay
hey everybody my name is andrew wright
from binging with babish and i'm here to
talk to you about my movie theater snack
essentials
[Music]
so what i'm gonna be doing today is
pitting movie theater snacks against one
another and seeing which one comes out
on top let's get messy
first up we have gummy candies uh we
have hottie bow gummy bears versus sour
patch kids as much as i love gummy bears
first off you have to sneak them in the
movie theater you can't buy these at the
movie theater i'll tell you why
[Applause]
when you get a pack of these what you
need to do is this you need to open them
up
let them sit for about a week i like for
them to be about as hard as a
naturally formed lava rock i like for
them to really put up a fight i like
stale gummy bears i do i like stale sour
patch kids too but also take them fresh
if need be because these are my favorite
gummy candy
these are my favorite gummy candy i once
ate so many of these i had to go to the
doctor because i had literal burns on my
mouth from all the sour did the same
thing with warheads too way easier to do
this it took some work it took some
doing took some expertise so
these are the winners
so next up we have junior mints versus
snow caps and there is only one clear
winner here
those are worse chocolate chips these
are better uh thin mints i love these
i'm gonna eat i said i wasn't gonna eat
any of these but i'm gonna eat every
single thing you throw at me probably
because these are so good especially if
you get them at just the right
consistency let's see what kind of
temperature these guys have been hanging
out at recently
oh oh my god
[Laughter]
that's perfect i never get these myself
somebody i go to the movies with always
gets one of these and i always take some
and if you give me some i'm always doing
that i'm just making a mess of myself
getting in my beard
saving some for later
oh besh
i love junior mints there's no
competition between these and chocolate
chips with sprinkles on them
[ __ ] out of here next up
so here we have the pantheon of
chocolate covered things we have
chocolate covered cookie dough bites
chocolate covered raisins aka regular
nuts and we have milk duds right off the
bat
get rid of that crap uh that i don't i'm
not going to the movie theater to eat
vegetables okay what i am here to do is
eat a whole bunch of chocolate and sugar
and now this is really going to depend
on the quality of the milk duds if these
are old
actually it's kind of good both ways
isn't it because when they're old they
get really chewy but when they're young
when they're fresh that's better they um
are softer this these feel well-aged
these feel like they've been around the
block
oh yeah
i'm going to be pulling out that out of
my teeth for the next half hour these
are fresh as a daisy let's see if i can
actually catch one of them
oh but not as good as i remember though
i remember this being so impossibly good
uh this one goes to milk duds i'm sorry
cookie dough bites you're one of my
all-time faves something about the
really stale caramel and just like the
old-timey chocolate in this really like
70s looking box there's something
special about it and uh i think it's
gonna take the chocolate covered game by
storm
what's next
oh no you guys are trying to get me
killed twizzlers versus
red vines
all right twizzlers versus red vines and
i have
an astonishing admission to make i have
never tried red vines in my life do red
vines have the hole in the middle
already
advantage red vines like i love the idea
of being able to plunge this into my
diet pepsi i don't drink diet pepsi
oh oh they taste awful
it tastes awful
it tastes like um i'm sorry i feel the
need to clean that up now i don't want
somebody to pick that up with their
hands
oh but that straw though that straw
that could do some serious beverage
sucking right now i'm coming out loud
and proud against red vines pro twizzler
all right
what's next
the battle of the savory carbs who will
come out on top find out tonight
on first we feast
we have buttered popcorn extra butter
and we have a warm pretzel with cheese
sauce granted this is not the one that
you get at the actual movie theater this
is an auntie anne's pretzel but
i'm gonna i'm gonna try to be you know
objective because
auntie ann's pretzel i'd rather have
this than a steak dinner honestly i
don't know why i'm eating it oh it's so
stale why am i doing this can't seem to
stop it's still happening and now i'm
putting it in my hand
those not travel well [ __ ] definitely
have to give this one to popcorn the the
movie theater pretzels are worse than
this is now they're pretty flavorless
they're like new york city street
pretzels which i'm a new yorker because
i've lived here for the requisite 10
years those are just garbage movie
theater popcorn however cannot be
emulated at home it is physically
impossible unless you have the
combination of flavacol
a giant popcorn machine that's been
making popcorn since the 90s and a stone
teenager doing it for you it's not gonna
come out the same and i doubt you have
those three things in your house you
might
but i doubt it this guy's gonna take the
crown it's movie theater popcorn what
kind of psycho would i be if in the
movie theater snacks episode i didn't
choose popcorn i'm not trying to get
shot
so there you have it folks some obvious
choices some controversial picks and a
whole lot of fun check out my channel
binging with babish i'm andrew ray and
this has been snacked
[Music]
you